.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Ben: ALSO HERE TONIGHT
FLORIDA SENATOR MARCO RUBIO.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Ben: I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THESE DEVELOPMENTS CONCERNING
THE DOJ POTENTIALLY CRACKING
DOWN ON WHAT OBVIOUSLY OUGHT TO
BE SOMETHING THAT PARENTS ARE
ABLE TO VOICE IN TERMS OF THEIR
CRITIQUES OF WHAT IS BEING
TAUGHT TO THEIR CHILDREN WITHIN
THESE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND TO THE
POLICIES OF THE SCHOOLS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS
NEWS BY DOJ.
>> FIRST OF ALL IT'S ALARM AND
AND SECOND OF ALL HYPOCRITICAL.
ALARMING THAT SOMEHOW IF PARENTS
SHOW UP AT SCHOOL BOARD TO
COMPLAIN, IF SOMEBODY THERE
DECIDES WE DON'T LIKE HIS TONE
OF VOICE WE DON'T LIKE HOW LOUD
IS HE SPEAK OR HOW OFTEN HE
SHOWS UP.
YOU CAN BE REPORTED.
THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION WHICH SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON THINGS LIKE ORGANIZED
CRIME.
THINGS LIKE DRUG TRAFFICKERS,
THINGS LIKE TERRORISM AND OTHERS
WHO SEEK TO HARM THIS COUNTRY IS
NOW GOING TO DIVERT RESOURCES TO
INVESTIGATE PARENTS BECAUSE THEY
SCREAM TOO LOUDLY OR MAYBE EVEN
RUDE AT SCHOOL BOARD HEARING AND
HYPOCRITICAL LET ME TELL YOU
VERY FEW OF SENATORS MEMBERS ON
THE RIGHT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AS
WELL WHO HAVE NOT BEEN HARASSED
IN THEIR PRIVATE LIFE.
NOW, OBVIOUSLY YOU JUST
INTERVIEWED SENATOR PAUL AND HE
HAS GONE THROUGH SOME PRETTY
EXTREME SITUATIONS.
BUT I PERSONALLY HAVE HAD PEOPLE
SHOW UP AT MY HOME WHEN I'M
THERE OR NOT THERE.
THEY DON'T RESPECT IF YOU ARE
HOME HAD PEOPLE THERE CONFRONT
MY FAMILY AT MY HOMES.
WE DON'T MAKE VIDEOS OUT OF IT
BUT THEY SOMETIMES DO.
I DON'T SEE AT LOVE CONCERN.
I WAS HERE A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WHEN THE SUPREME COURT HEARINGS
WERE GOING ON THERE, WERE
SENATORS BEING CHASED INTO
ELEVATORS AND DOWN THE HALL.
THE WAY IT WAS COVERED BY A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THE PRESSES, YOU
GET WHAT YOU DESERVE.
YOU DESERVE TO BE RUN OUT.
AND, IN FACT, YOU HAD MAXINE
WATERS AND OTHERS ON TELEVISION
BASICALLY SAYING IF YOU SEE
THESE PEOPLE OUT IN PUBLIC.
SCREAM AT THEM.
NOT JUST BE NASTY AND RUDE TO
THEM.
TRY TO INTIMIDATE THEM.
THEY HAVE NORMALIZED THIS
BEHAVIOR WHEN THIS COMES TO LEFT
WING PROTESTERS BUT THEN WHEN A
PARENT SPEAKS OUT ABOUT A SCHOOL
BOARD, THEY WANT TO SICK THE FBI
ON THEM.
THIS IS CRAZY.
LIKE IF YOU WOULD HAVE TOLD ME
FIVE YEARS AGO THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN I WOULD SAY THERE IS NO
WAY SOMETHING LIKE THIS WOULD
HAPPEN.
IT'S HAPPENING.
>> Ben: SENATOR, I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION FOR YOU ON A DIFFERENT
TOPIC.
I'M VERY CONCERNED ONE OF THE
RESULTS OF THIS GOING TO BE
THERE IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
SECURITY DETAILS FOR EVERY U.S.
SENATOR AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WE HAVE ALWAYS PRIDED OURSELVES
ON THE ABILITY OF CITIZENS TO BE
ABLE TO AFROZEN THE SENATOR AND
HAVE ACCESS TO TALK TO THEM OVER
THE YEARS.
ARE THOSE DAYS GOING TO BE IN
THE PAST FOR US?
>> I DON'T THINK HAVING A
SECURITY DETAIL FOR EVERY MEMBER
OF CONGRESS IS POSSIBLE.
I DON'T THINK YOU COULD DO THAT
YOU HAVE COULDN'T AFFORD IT AND
COULDN'T HIRE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
DO THAT.
IT WOULDN'T BE PRACTICAL.
WHAT IS GOING IT HAPPEN HERE IS
SOMETHING TERRIBLE IS GOING TO
HAPPEN EVENTUALLY BECAUSE WE
HAVE BASICALLY NORMALIZED THIS
BEHAVIOR.
UNDERSTAND, IT'S HYPOCRITICAL
BECAUSE THE LEFT SAYS IF YOU ARE
DOING IT TO SOMEONE ON THE
RIGHT.
THEY DESERVE IT IF YOU ARE DOING
IT TO SOMEONE ON THE LEFT, OR
SOMEONE WHO COMES FROM THEIR
AGENDA, YOU SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD LIVE TO
SEE THE DAY THAT THIS KIND OF
THING WOULD BE HAPPENING IN
COUNTRY.
BUT IT IS.
>> Ben: I KNOW THAT YOU ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
AT THE BORDER THAT WE HAVE BEEN
COVERING HERE AT FOX OVER THE
PAST WEEKS AND MONTHS.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE IN TERMS OF
ANY KIND OF APPROACH THAT CAN BE
DONE TO ACTUALLY MAKE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION RESPOND TO THIS
PARTICULARLY SUPPOSED BORDER
CZAR KAMALA HARRIS.
>> KAMALA HARRIS SHOULDN'T BE
THE BORDER CZAR SHE ISN'T DOING
ANYTHING.
IF SHE IS THEY NEED TO FIND
SOMEBODY ELSE.
HAITIAN MIGRANTS ALONE BETWEEN
90 AND 120,000 HAITIAN MIGRANTS
SOME OF WHOM HAVE BEEN LIVING IN
CHILE OR ECUADOR FOR THE BETTER
PART OF 10 YEARS WHO NOW, THOSE
COUNTRIES RAN OUT OF JOBS AND SO
NOW THEY ARE LOOKING TO MAKE THE
JOURNEY NORTH.
THEY'RE AT VARIOUS STAGES OF
TRANSIT.
WE ARE BEING TOLD THAT COUNTRY
AND COUNTRY REASONABLE.
NOT JUST FROM HAITI ALONE.
NOT TO MENTION 9 OTHER PLACES.
IF YOU TALK TO PEOPLE AT THE
BORDER, PEOPLE THAT HAVE
CROSSED, THEY WILL ALL TELL YOU
THE SAME THING.
THEY EXPECT TO GET INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY EXPECT TO ENTER.
THEY EXPECT TO BE RELEASED.
PENDING AN ASYLUM HEARING THAT
MANY HAVE NO INTENTION TO SHOW
UP FOR.
AND WHEN THEY MAKE THE JOURNEY
THEY CALL BACK HOME, THEY LET
OTHER PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT IT AND
TEN COURTROOMS MORE PEOPLE TO DO
THE SAME.
IT'S A ROLLING CATASTROPHE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SEE
INCIDENTS LIKE WHAT WE SAW JUST
TWO WEEKS AGO AND MY HEART BREAK
FOR PEOPLE FROM HAITI AND ALL
OVER THE WORLD NO.
NATION ON EARTH CAN HAVE THE
OPEN BORDER WE BASICALLY HAVE
NOW AND JUST TELL ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO COME PLEASE SHOW UP.
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION THINKS THEY ARE
GOING TO DO.
IF KAMALA HARRIS IS THE ONE IN
CHARGE OF THIS, THEY NEED TO
FIND SOMEBODY ELSE AND FAS